[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
je pense que j'ai été influencé ce soir
positivement inspirer par la dernière
intervenante son histoire est croyant et
dit dans un langage assez simple je
pense que c'est des choses importantes
quoi j'avais commencé à m'endormir mais
là il m'a réveillé merci
on a bien reçu les statuts
je profite de l'occasion pour dire merci
et bravo aux organisateurs du TEDx parce
que c'est important il faut pouvoir
partager ce qu'on a comme expérience
avec les plus jeunes bon je suis
peut-être le doyen en âge peut-être dans
la salle
des précédents intervenants qu'est-ce
qu'on a retenu
discipline super héros rêve humilité la
fraude du digital et son influence la
mentalité à tout épreuve je pense que
l'essentiel est là dans ce message
j'avais préparé quelque chose d'un peu
plus fine après au cours avec les
différents interventions j'ai dit
orienter pour faire pour rendre un peu
plus digeste et adapter un peu à la
circonstances donc mon histoire vous
avez vu
la présentatrice a parlé de mon de mon
parcours mais derrière ce parcours se
cachent une histoire peut-être que
beaucoup ne savent pas je vais me forcer
de le rendre plus synthétique d'abord
c'était même pas prédestiné à aller à
l'école française à l'école
ce que beaucoup ne savent pas mon père
était à Bouvines il était imam et je
suis le dernier ici son dernier donc
naturellement je dirais son successeur
j'ai fait le col coranique très tôt à
l'âge de 3 ans je partais à l'école
coranique et les jours on partait pas à
l'école coranique on parle sur la
compagnie il y a le chant
à 7 ans
tous les enfants du quartier sont à
l'école il a mis un veto il dit je parle
pas
c'est difficile il a fallu un de ses
amis béninois qui était locataire chez
nous qu'il a convaincu il lui a dit ben
envoie l'enfant à l'école je me charge
des frais de scolarité il dit non je
sais pas une question de moyens mais
c'est un principe lui il veut que son
fils soit imam qui a sur la continuité
et là moi j'avais envie d'aller à
l'école comme tout le monde à l'école
française mais j'ai rien dit c'était la
volonté de ne pas perdre son âme des
discussions en discussion finalement il
a cédé avec des conditions strictes tu
reprends pas de classe je ne paye pas
les fournitures de la même de la même
année et que tu sois premier dernier
c'est pas mon problème tu vas à l'école
pour toi
donc là je commence le CPA avec toute la
pression un peu plus tard c'est un 2008
ans donc j'arrive au CPA commence la
scolarité je n'avais pas de soi je dis
j'ai pas de choix que d'être premier
mais pour moi même pour prouver que là
je peux donc il s'est payé jusqu'au CM2
premier de classe
et là voilà je viens je lui demande des
résultats et dit mais qu'est-ce que tu
veux que je dise tu vas à l'école pour
toi même pas de félicitations jamais de
félicitations
c'est payant ça j'arrive à l'entrée en
6e
le jour de l'examen de l'entrée en 6e en
6e panique
l'épreuve de mathématiques qui sait pas
ce qui s'est passé j'ai invité
je compose
après les résultats tombent j'ai laissé
et le premier déclare ce n'est pas
rentré en 6e
premier échec
il a dit voilà c'est fini là
tu reprends à l'école coranique en même
temps que je partais à l'école les jours
fériés les jours on n'avait pas à
l'école des jours de repos je contiens
de l'école coranique je n'ai jamais
regardé la télé la 6e du CP1 jusqu'à CM2
jamais de télé les amis les dimanches
ils vont regarder
moi je partais à l'école Coralie jamais
donc on me demande pourquoi j'adore la
télé l'origine vient de là moi je passe
des heures je peux je dors avec la télé
je me réveille avec la télé le résumé
j'ai jamais regardé la télé jusqu'à en
6e
et là je reprends la classe
encore primé de ma classe avec des très
bonnes moyennes j'arrive
j'ai lancé en 6e super tout le monde est
content sauf mon père oui mais tu vas à
l'école tu as déjà échouer tes amis sont
tes amis sont en 5e toi tu vas en 6e tu
es nul
je continue j'arrive on m'orient d'un
collège privé avant qu'on partait d'un
collège d'établissement privé c'est un
échec moi je voulais aller au lycée
moderne Dago ville au collège moderne je
me retrouve dans un lycée un petit
collège moderne tecroly
mon père il vient à la charge tu vois tu
n'es pas bon les meilleurs sont au lycée
toi tu retrouves dans un collège privé
et là c'est l'horreur je continue je dis
je n'ai pas d'autres choix que d'être
meilleur de la 6e jusqu'à en 3e 1er
déclaration premier déclasse et là je
suis sélectionné pour aller meilleur
élève d'agouville je vais au lycée
scientifique
c'est important cette phrase
donc quand j'arrive au lycée
scientifique premier devoir de
mathématiques moi j'avais les 19 le
premier devoir de mathématiques 4 sur 20
le premier de la région de la nébi hein
premier de la nuit quatre sur 20 il nous
fallait 12 de moyenne passer en série C
et là le prof de maths
il a fait une démonstration et puis j'ai
éclaté de rire et là il avait signé mon
arrêt de mort
j'ai signé mon arrêt de mort parce que
c'est le prof de maths et le prof de
physique-chimie qui décidait du passage
en série C
il a mis la base c'était 12 de moyenne
il a regardé les moyens j'étais à 12,99
il a passé la moins de passage en série
cash
je vais en série D
et là j'ai dit à mon père
je ne crois pas donc je vais en série D
voilà je me suis éclaté première d voilà
je m'éclate j'ai mon bac
quand c'est mon bac
je voulais qu'on va en série de ce
médecin ou la mort donc c'est écrit aux
chevaux de mon lion scientifique merci
de la mort
en ce moment parfois on est institut le
train commun des sciences médicales
c'est la première on était la première
promotion des sciences médicales et à
l'INP à l'insec à l'époque c'était
l'insept ce qui est devenu inp-hb ils
ont institué les classes préparatoires
commerciales
c'est la première fois avant de rentrer
directement à l'escarre voilà classe
préparatoire
je dis ben écoute
la rentrée scolaire à l'université sans
janvier moi je suis en octobre je vais
aller à l'INSEP en classe préparatoire
tu me fais trois mois de bourse parce
que je sais que papa ne va pas me donner
de l'argent et après je vais à
l'université ça me permettra d'aller
être cambodgien avec un de mes amis lui
donner un peu d'argent pour avoir accès
à la chambre
donc je vais je reste
c'est pour dire que ma vie est fait
d'opportunités après trois mois je me
sens à l'aise je décide de rester à
l'entrée parce que il y avait la chambre
individuelle de l'eau chaude le petit
déjeuner avec 7500 francs on avait tout
le repas du mois et j'avais une bourse
de 40 000 francs à l'époque c'est génial
je reste même pas par Objectif scolaire
il y avait rien de logique moi j'ai
saisi l'opportunité voilà c'est ça ma
vie
je sais une opportunité là et ça peut
payer je sais une opportunité ce qu'on
m'a fait l'a dit j'ai saisi une
opportunité j'avais une chambre de l'eau
chaude j'avais un repas qui était offert
et puis voilà j'ai dit bon écoute j'ai
la capacité de pouvoir étudier je fais
je fais les classes préparatoires en ce
moment le programme n'était même pas
défini
on nous faisait faire les mathématiques
des prépas techno on a fait les mêmes
devoirs que les ingénieurs
voilà on fait le concours je suis admis
je rentre à l'ESCA ça se passe bien
voilà on va en pré-emploi ça c'est
important quand je dis ma vie est fait
d'opportunités je fais un stage
d'entretien chez Nelson parce que moi
j'ai pris la filière marketing
c'est ce que je voulais toujours faire
peut-être que c'est fan de savais même
pas ça
marketing donc j'arrive je fais un
entretien chez Nelson Macan peut-être
qu'on aurait été concluant aujourd'hui
c'est Nelson c'était la plus grosse
agence on me dit les résultats de
l'entretien c'est dans 3 jours j'ai un
autre entretien chez
l'entretien à 11h on m'appelle à 15h
si mon contrat j'ai oublié ma canne j'ai
oublié le marketing je vais en finance
je vais en finance je me retrouve en
tant qu'auditeur financier
voilà c'est vraiment des opportunités
après il faut avoir une assurance il
faut se dire que quel que soit le
domaine d'activité quel que soit
l'environnement on peut s'adapter il
faut être à Gilly c'est le message clé
que je veux faire passer en terme
d'agilité j'arrive chez un seigneur on
démarre assistant 1 assistant de
malheureusement c'est un patron un
Guinéen personal
vraiment ce monsieur il m'a torturé mais
il m'a pris beaucoup de choses
pendant 5 ans il m'a dit que j'étais nul
5 ans donc je passe un message à tous
ces jeunes qui à toutes les personnes
même plus jeunes qui sont en entreprise
qui se plaignent d'avoir un mauvais
patron il est en griffe chiant il nous
emmerde n'abandonnez pas
continuer à bosser c'est votre travail
qui va faire parler de vous qui va
laisser des tracer important pendant
cinq ans
j'étais avec mes assistants un jour j'ai
envoyé un dossier jette mais les
assistants veulent ramasser le dessus
non non j'étais super bizarre non ta
Libye tu prends le dossier
humilité je prends mon dossier je vais
ranger
au bout de la rentrée de la 6e année
l'assistante m'appelle Talibi qui est
observe tu ne dis rien tout le monde
refuse de travailler avec ce monsieur tu
as laissé la Boula travaille avec lui
mais je te dis quelque chose tout est
rapports qui sont qui sont pas bons des
mauvais rapport ton mauvais anglais tout
ça c'est le même rapport que j'envoie à
Londres en France on change même pas une
virgule
et là 5 ans après ça prend que celui qui
est mauvais qui n'est pas bon qui fait
de mauvais rapport il est brillant je ne
dis rien et je reçois un coup de fil de
connaissez bien l'entrepreneur connu de
sanguine
il m'appelle j'étais vers sokossé dans
ma dans ma voiture d'occasion qui
démarrait une fois sur deux donc
j'arrive me dire bonjour monsieur
Haïdara
Talibi je te veux président
on peut pas discuter de ça au téléphone
donc j'étais au niveau de ce conseil je
venais d'engrais
au Bénin
ok je t'ai envoyé un billet d'avion tu
me trouves au Burkina j'arrive au
Burkina en entretien du 5 minutes il dit
je t'engage mais bas voir le sillon à
Abidjan pour finaliser les éléments
contractuels non j'ai une contrainte
l'offre intéressante mon salaire de
multiplier pratiquement pas deux je dis
non je dis j'ai une contrainte il faut
que j'ai la bénédiction de mon patron je
vais voir le fameux patron
qui dit que je suis nul j'ai dit j'ai
une offre intéressante je dois partir
mon opposition de directeur financier au
bénin mais je ne partirai qu'avec ta
bénédiction la loyauté peu importe quel
que soit les contraintes il faut être
loyal
et dit je ne partirai qu'avec ta
bénédiction
je te donne la route
mais retiens que le cabinet vient de
perdre ce jour un de ses plus brillants
éléments
6 ans de frustration effacées en une
petite phrase et là je parle à la tête
haute j'arrive au Bénin
je suis avec mon patron le DG c'est un
blanc c'est un français très sympathique
on collabore bien et de temps en temps
je reçois des demandes d'information du
groupe
on me demande des informations on bypass
mon DG
l'information financière du porting et
dès que je traite je vais voir le DG
j'ai dit mais ton boss m'a demandé une
information mais je t'envoie pour que tu
lui transferts
en copie chaque fois et puis après il me
dit mais c'est à toi j'ai demandé mais
pas attendu mais jusqu'à preuve du
contraire sauf ton respect le big boss
c'est lui qui me paye
c'est mon deuxième local qui me paye la
loyauté c'est important
donc
je l'ai fait et puis chaque fois c'était
le même procédé je passais par lui je
l'ai informé de tout ce que je vais
faire j'en connais peut-être d'autres
plus jeunes aurait pris sa communauté de
pouvoir le contourner voilà ça c'est
important à éviter
donc
une année et demi après c'était le plus
jeune dans mon comité direction 35 ans
les autres avec 45 ans 50 ans il sait le
plus jeune une année et demi après il
affecté au Burkina on lui demande qui
peut te remplacer dis les yeux fermés
cette alibi
comme DG
on dit tu es suivi bon il y avait
quelques réticences au niveau du conseil
d'administration te donne une intérim
six mois après je suis confirmé comme
directeur général de move au Bénin on
avait on était à 100000 abonnés on est
vraiment que je ne parte on était à 1
million d'abonnés
donc ce qui se passe la partie la plus
importante en 2017 on s'appelait Télécel
avant on change de nom on passe à Moov
le gouvernement du Bénin profite de
l'occasion pour vous la changer le prix
des licences
en voulant changer le prix de licence on
parle de 5 milliards à 30 milliards et
nous on refuse de signer
suspension du réseau pendant deux mois
et j'ai 400 employés sous ma main
après un moment donné les gens ils sont
là c'est au niveau du groupe produits on
va fermer la filière et puis on passe à
autre chose quoi c'est bon on ferme la
filiale on pourra pas payer et je
commence les discussions je vais voir
feu le professeur on échange il me dit
ben écoute est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
à payer les 30 millions on dit ouais et
30 milliards si on peut les transmis
avec moi il me faut de la contrepartie
pour convaincre non seulement les gens
d'Abidjan aussi combien que les gens de
Dubaï parce que c'est le groupe était
affilié aux émiratis
il faut des contreparties c'est là qu'on
travaille avec les équipes on y met en
face des contreparties exonération
douanières fiscale et autres pour que
dans la balance ça puisse avoir un effet
neutre puisqu'on était dans un plan de
déploiement
après la pression forte
au journal télévisé il y a un ministre
qui vient il s'agit d'une guerre de
libération économique ces
multinationales qui viennent piller
l'économie du pays mais là j'ai dit je
vais en prison là là c'est fini je vais
en prison
donc là souvent tu es dans la rue tu
vois des motos derrière tu penses qu'il
y a des agents de l'enseignement tu es
payé tout ça
donc là il faut aller réfléchir
autrement les discussions étaient
tendues on n'avait pas de port de sortie
je décide de organiser une conférence de
presse je prends le soin d'informer un
ami la présidence qu'on organise une
conférence de presse
l'organisme de la conférence de presse
c'est mes avocats qui diraient prononcer
la conférence de presse au dernier
moment la dernière seconde là ils disent
qu'il peut faire donc qu'est-ce que je
fais et je suis face à mon destin je
décide de prendre le micro et je dis
voilà mes mots quand dans un pays des
gens sont incapables et qui n'arrivent
pas à conseiller la Haute Autorité
on arrive à cette situation de blocage
qui n'est ni bon pour les opérateurs ni
bon pour l'état du Bénin
pareil circonstances on ne peut que se
remettre à la Haute Autorité seule
personne capable de pouvoir nous sortir
de cette situation
j'ai dit le ministre tous les ministres
de ils sont nuls les conseillers sont
nuls qui ne personne le président le nom
nous reçoit en audience
le Président nous reçoit il dit ben
écoutez on rentre
à 18h
téléphone n'a pas de téléphone
encore mais les gens que j'ai insulté la
veille savait que je vais négocier
donc là tu n'arrives même pas à prévenir
la famille personne tu es là tu as coupé
du monde on se retrouve dans une salle
de 20h jusqu'à 24 heures jusqu'à minuit
aujourd'hui tu vas voir mais ensemble ça
va tu vas voir je les ai laissés en
terme de stratégie de négociation c'est
important l'épuisement
j'ai laissé ici
mais il va falloir qu'on trouve un
accord parce que le chef nous attend à
6h
donc on est aussi après moi je dois
appeler les gens de Dubaï et on arrive à
avoir un accord on paie on a le
contrepartie on vient aussi quand on
sort le soir conférence du prêt on dit
les opérateurs acceptés nous on a on
accepte de payer on a le même pas de
contrepartie on signe ok on sort là mais
tu vois l'autre le retournement de
situation c'était la superstar là quand
je sors là
dans la ville mais les gens en moto il
m'acclame partout je ne consomme pas
d'alcool mais je me suis retrouvé avec
une vingtaine de bouteilles de champagne
dans des karaoké dans des boîtes de nuit
réservées avec des tables parce qu'on
sortait d'une situation où les gens
n'avaient pas à communiquer pendant deux
mois
donc dès qu'on sort les personnalité qui
que j'ai insulté la pression de lui-même
meilleur ami il y a un même que j'ai vu
avant-hier et c'était super donc tout ça
pour dire quoi en terme d'enseignement
face à une situation donnée il faut il
faut avoir une bonne maîtrise une bonne
lecture de l'environnement c'est vrai
parfois vous allez vous sentir seul
les gens ils vont vouloir fermer
peut-être moi la décision du groupe
peut-être que c'est de fermer mais
croyez en vous
mener le bon combat quand vous êtes
convaincu que vous menez le bon combat
je prends l'exemple de Texas gris puis
des autres
allez jusqu'au bout
et après bon voilà quand je sors de là
je un sentiment
de devoir accomplir je retourne à
Abidjan rapidement je viens au groupe
comme substratégique officiel et après
c'était fatigué de PowerPoint de
stratégie et décide de repartir à
l'école il va HEC
je démarre ici après ça change ça prend
le premier coup je dis mais là je peux
plus rester à l'entreprise c'est là j'ai
démissionne mais quand je suis revenu
j'étais expatrié dans mon propre pays
expatrié à Beverly Hills
jambandonne tout ça pour être
entrepreneur de quoi tu sais même pas
sérieux je ne savais pas je dis je veux
plus travailler mon lit il est fou on
propose même à mon épouse d'aller
prendre une étape Adjamé non mais c'est
vraiment la famille tout ça c'est pas
possible
donc j'abandonne j'ai fait je l'ai pas
dit que j'ai fait un dépanner aussi et
j'avais quand même un petit matelas de
sécurité donc je démarre c'est là que je
démarre ma carrière dans
l'entrepreneuriat et je profite pour
faire mon ma thèse de mémoire sur
l'entreprise et 2 ans et demi une année
et demi après prix d'excellence du
meilleur promoteur immobilier de Côte
d'Ivoire
voilà et là il fallait il faut croire
quoi
et après bon comme le temps c'était je
disais un peu aux organisateurs si je
vais dérouler à chaque étape il y a des
enseignements moi c'est important c'est
ce que je veux que vous reteniez vous
qui êtes là retenez ça je t'ai pas
dessiné à l'école française je l'ai fait
je t'ai pas dessiné à faire de la
finance je l'ai fait après maintenant
qu'est-ce que je fais j'essaie de rendre
ce que je peux je suis qu'au directeur
académique dans le programme à
chaussures à chez ce challenge plus pour
la formation des jeunes entrepreneurs on
a la troisième promo et aussi je suis
coach à ses sœurs à la SFI société
financier internationale pour
accompagner les différents promoteurs
immobiliers
pour moi le plus important thème
d'enseignement qu'il learning
quelle trace je laisse
de mon parcours professionnel premier
point deuxième point quelle image tu
laisses quand je quitte l'entreprise
aujourd'hui dans n'importe quelle
entreprise qui cherche Huawei et c'est
comme chez moi
et après quand on arrive à une étape de
sa carrière qu'est-ce qu'on transmet
c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui à tout
le monde moi je conseille ce que
j'appelle la méthode step step comme pas
en anglais c'est le sérieux le travail
l'excellence et le professionnalisme
parce que c'est step by step qu'on se
construit une bonne belle carrière
professionnelle je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]